HOW PEOPLE AROUND THWORLD ARE
DIFFERT
WHEN IT COTO TRUTH, RACE
AND GENDER AND WIDENITIES.
>> YOUREE HAVING THESE
FE
WAYTO MAKE IT, SPOKE  OF E PUIC
SAID TO ME GIVE MEE TO
TALK TTHES THE
AMANCONCERNED ABOUT,'S BTHAT
OF POLICY BUT DOESN'T ALWAYS KE
COALESCE AROUN
OVER TIMEIT IT  NOTW,
TH LTH AOT
OF REPUBLICANGJOHN McCAIN WAS
THE BLAN
THAT S
OHA
ERTILL A BCH OF LIY
CONSERVATIVE THAN I AMN
,  TLA ISSUES ONESOOD PEOPLEAND,
BUS  PARTLY  WHEINTH HAP
DAYS, THE INFORMATION, IF YOU'RN
FOX NEWSOR FOLLOWING SOME RIGHT
ORT  TO YOU RERKIMAND SUCH FUNDD
SKEWEDE WORLDVIEWS ARE S
ONE DIRECTION NOTHER IT'S VEACYO
WOUNDATION
OTHEIND
, HIM ENGAGING IN,
ANST DURING
EACH OTHER. TION OF THE OTHER AF
UNFORTUNATELY I THIT
OF THESE CHALLENGE  I WANT  ASK
GOT TO THEM FINATHE FIRST BLACIC
NEEDTO WFOR YO
ANW LYSTWH
AGAINST K PRESIDCY,
LO  RECEDING, AND ITDO YTE
GOVERNOR OF SOUTH CAROLINA
SCOTT, SENATOR OF
S KEE AS PART
OF THE EQUATION, AND
CHDON'T LEAVTHAT EVEBOEQUA
MATTER WHAR LO
>> I WILL COMMENT IC CRUNNIN SON
OTHEOCCUPYTHK LWAYS BEEN
N
LIFE IN IT  TSERVER IN
SIDEIS  LY NOT BEEN
DENT, ABRAHAM
DID AN AWFUL LOT TOOF
CONVERSELY, THE IC
CIVIL TSRE FOR
YEAR
OW.
ITTOH FOR
I THINK WEEARESSKEPTICALPOST-RA
IDCY, I EO WOF THEROS POSSIBLEI
THT  IOR WE RECKONED WITH  THAT
INCREASINGLYTY,
PART OF I THINK L OF U NTHUNITEE
HUNG
ESCE PARTICUY
TI STRESS AROU TRIBE,
WTECES AR
POLITICIANS OOD WAY OF
RTANDON'T
RESIST THA HAVE
PROBLEMSNOIC,
E THTHE
SUAS WELL, ENDER ROLES
ASRAAL R G
AND THE LI
TRADITIONAL STURARCHIECH WHEN H
SEXUALENTATIAY
HERE AND I WANT A T ISN THREAND
MENTN.
HE ECONOMIC
ELEMENT TOURRACY THAT
ATTEN
ACOI
INEQUALIE'N ALIZATION AND AUTOMN
THE DECLINE THINK OF NEWS
LLY WE
NOT TALKING ABOUT THAT
E,R GE, I DE
D  DEAD, MIGRANTS, NLOST AT THER
APPARENTLY
SMUGGLED HERE,WS NOT DOMINATING
THE DEGREH PEOPLE'SWAYS I
MASSIVE CONCENTRATF  YOU
ALOFMENT
ECONOMIE SERIOUSLY THE EDLEA S